[Musik]
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
begrüße sie herzlich zur pressekonferenz
mit verteidigungsminister in klaudia
tanner mit dem generalstabschef des
österreichischen bundesheers genau
robert präge und dem gruppenleiter der
grundsatz planung
verteidigungsministeriums general winter
hofbauer und nicht auf die
verteidigungsministerien der suche zu
beginnen
ja sehr geehrte damen und herren das
österreichische bundesheer ist auch
heute wieder im großeinsatz
so beginnt heute auch unser
großflächiger assistenzeinsatz in tirol
bevor ich auf die details der
beschaffungen der kommenden monate und
jahre eingehen möchte will ich ihnen
daher einen überblick über die aktuell
laufenden einsätze geben
aktuell befinden sich drei 1969
soldatinnen und soldaten des
bundesheeres im in- und im ausland im
einsatz davon sind 906 im
assistenzeinsatz migration 203
soldatinnen und soldaten im objektschutz
sind im einsatz sie wissen seit dem
furchtbaren terroranschlag am zweiten
november rund 2000 soldatinnen und
soldaten befinden sich im coebad einsatz
davon beginnend mit heute eben allein
664 in der ruhe
sie unterstützen bei der umsetzung der
gesundheitsbehörden maßnahmen und
abseits dessen sind wir mit rund 900
soldatinnen und soldaten im
auslandseinsatz und mit einer abordnung
der garde unterstützend auch bei der
hotline des außenministeriums tätig sie
sehen sehr geehrte damen und herren
unser heer ist auch beinahe ein jahr
nach beginn der pandemie unglaublich
gefordert damit das österreichische
bundesheer seine aufgaben auch erfüllen
kann müssen wir laufend nachrüsten um
weiterhin auch für österreich und immer
für österreich da sein zu können
als ich in dieses hause gekommen bin war
mein erster eindruck
eigentlich ist es unglaublich denn hier
ist beinahe alles so alt wie ich oder
noch älter aber scherzhaft gesagt wir
haben tatsächlich einen sehr großen
investitionsrückstau gemeinsam mit and i
ffi ziert und uns dazu entschieden
diesen rückstau stück für stück
abzubauen
ja und wir haben diese möglichkeit auch
mit der zweimaligen erhöhung des budgets
das jetzt auch anzupacken
wir haben parallel zum regel budget zu
diesem zweck eine gesunde in westpakete
ausverhandelt und diese pakete
orientieren sich an jenen bereichen in
denen wir gemeinsam den größten bedarf
auch identifiziert haben
ich möchte mit der miliz beginnen sie
wissen im vergangenen jahr wurde
erstmals in der geschichte die miliz
aufgeboten und diese historische
maßnahme hat uns dann auch gleichzeitig
einen klaren blick gegeben an welchen
schrauben wir erst möglich drehen müssen
und wir haben dann gemeinsam mit unserem
miliz beauftragten geheime hannes eder
vor einigen monaten ihnen ja bereits
einen einblick in das miliz paket
gegeben wir investieren insbesondere in
die bereiche der mannes ausrüstung
mobilität der führungsunterstützung
sowie in die bewaffnung gerade in dieser
krise brauche ich ihnen sehr geehrte
damen und herren nicht sagen wie wichtig
die abc abwehr
für uns ist von der masken überprüfung
bis hin zu den über 400 desinfektions
einsätzen war die abc abwehr unseres
heeres gefordert wie wohl schon lange
nicht
und in diesem bereich werden wir mit
rund 25 millionen euro pro jahr bis 2024
um einen einmal die schutzausrüstung der
soldaten erneuern wie mobilität
verbessern
das equipment für die dekontamination
und anderes notwendiges gerät anschaffen
und gestern es waren ja einige von ihnen
auch mit dabei waren wir im
sanitätszentrum ost in wien wo derzeit
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten aus dem
sanitätswesen geimpft werden
sie waren und sie sind es die über
monate hinweg bereits bei den testungen
maßgeblich mitwirken
und auch da haben wir gesehen dass
gerade dieser bereich des bundesheeres
in den letzten jahren wirklich
stiefmütterlich behandelt worden ist und
so haben wir uns entschieden diesen
bereich nun wieder zu einer neuen größe
zu bringen
daher wird neben dem sanitäts konzept
das derzeit in finalisierung ist 25
millionen euro jährlich in den
geschützten den ungeschützten sondern
sanitäts transport investiert was auch
noch notwendig ist ist dass wir
medizinische gerätschaften austauschen
modernisieren und auch erweitern das
jahr 2020 hat für uns auch einen cyber
angriff auf das außenministerium
bedeutet es sind ja weitere dieser
angriffe dann auch gefolgt und so werden
wir neben unserem neuen ik t management
studiengang an der militärakademie in
wiener neustadt den wir weiter gemeinsam
präsentieren dürfen so werden die auch
in diesen bereich rund 25 millionen euro
jährlich bis 2024 investieren
das ist notwendig für die errichtung
einer seiner ranch für die verbesserung
der fähigkeiten insbesondere in der
elektronischen kampfführung jan wenn wir
so zurückblicken dann sehen wir auch das
auch bei katastropheneinsätzen infolge
von naturkatastrophen das bundesheer
immer wieder ein notwendiger partner war
für die feuerwehren für andere zivile
organisationen das war
und das sind wir
wenn sie nur denken an muren an
waldbrände hochwasser und lawinen
neben der beschaffung der neuen
hubschrauber um in etwa 300 millionen
euro die ja auch in diesem bereich oder
insbesondere in diesem bereich stark zum
einsatz kommen werden werden wir um 25
millionen euro jährlich union ihr gerät
kaufen
das reicht von pioneer maschinen bis hin
zu fahrzeugen und andere anderen
transportsystemen ich habe kurz schon
den furchtbaren terroranschlag
angesprochen vom zweiten november an
diesem tag haben wir sind wir den
einsatz gerufen worden haben den
objektschutz übernommen führen wir nach
wie vor noch durch und zum anderen
bereit zu sein wenn die polizei uns bei
der planung der gefahr benötigt daher
ist es auch in diesem bereich notwendig
zu investieren in den bereich der
terrorabwehr
was meinen wir damit das reicht von der
drohnen abwehr bis hin zur
modernisierung vom waffensystem abseits
dessen habe ich vor zwei wochen den
vertrag für die beschaffung von 30 neuen
weiteren pandur radpanzer mit einem
volumen von über 100 millionen euro
unterzeichnet diese panzer werden
genutzt um unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten sicher hin und aus der
gefahrenzone bringen zu können
neben diesen großen paketen die ich
angesprochen habe ist es auch notwendig
laufend zu investieren laufend in unsere
kasernen und in deren autarkie zu
investieren
wer den zustand etlicher kasernen kennt
der weiß dass es mit der autarkie nicht
getan ist und wir müssen daher auch jede
nasszelle jeden schlafraum in den
kommenden jahren in einen herz- bahn
zustand bringen
sehr geehrte damen und herren sie sehen
wir haben viel vor wir werden viel
investieren wir werden
viel investieren müssen gerade aber am
heutigen tag ist es mir auch ein
persönliches bedürfnis danke zu sagen
danke all den männern und frauen im
dienste der republik den soldatinnen
soldaten den zivilbediensteten die
unglaubliches leisten
zur sicherheit der österreicherinnen und
österreicher und ich sehe es oder wir
sehen es auch als unsere persönliche
aufgabe an diesen männern und frauen
equipment und die rahmenbedingungen zu
geben die sie brauchen um ihre aufgaben
auch angemessen und vor allem sicher
erfüllen zu können und das tun wir
ich danke ihnen vielen dank bitte herr
general sehr geehrte frau bundesminister
sehr geehrte damen und herren bevor
generalmajor hofbauer über aktuelle
investitionen und anschaffungen des
österreichischen bundesheeres berichtet
darf ich ihre aufmerksamkeit auf einen
bereich richten der schon öfter in der
diskussion war und das ist der bereich
der panzer und panzergrenadiere des
österreichischen bundesheeres sie wissen
dass diese truppengattung seit dem
kalten krieg um etwa 62 prozent
reduziert wurde und das in den haupt
system und das betrifft den kampfpanzer
leopard und den schützenpanzer ulan
seit dieser einführung ende der 90er
jahre kaum investitionen erfolgt sind
das war auch geschuldet beim damaligen
konflikt bild und der reaktion darauf
dass nach dem kalten krieg das
hauptaugenmerk des militärs auf
auslandseinsätze gerichtet war
nunmehr hat sich das konflikt bild aber
wesentlich weiter entwickelt und
gestaltet sich differenzierter es sind
über die einsatzzwecke
dieser druck gattung viele diskussionen
geführt worden und das ergebnis kann
zusammenfassend so gesehen werden dass
das aufgabenspektrum
dieser fahrzeuge und dieser truppen
konventionelle und hybride szenarien
umfasst diese beiden szenarien können
sich auch überschneiden
denken sie etwa an terroristische
gruppen die militärisch organisiert sind
und auch sich militärischer einsatz
mittel bedienen und die eben nur durch
robuste reaktion entsprechend
beantwortet werden können gesamtheitlich
verbleibt wenn man das so sehen will
weltweit die mechanisierte truppe als
träger des sogenannten kampf ist er
verbunden und waffen man kann auch von
einem einsatz der verbündeten mittel
sprechen durchaus auch in einem modernen
gefechts bild dass wir gegenwärtig und
für die zukunft erwarten wenn man nun
den blick über die grenzen berichtet
sehr geehrte damen und herren
dann wird man feststellen dass weltweit
diese gepanzerten kräfte verstärkt
modernisiert oder ersetzt werden
unser nachbarland ungarn etwa schafft
ein bataillon hochmodernen leopard 2 a7
panzer an daneben
die panzerhaubitze 2000 ebenfalls
deutscher herkunft und zahlreiche neue
schützenpanzer es werden neue einsatz
rollen definiert wenn sie den blick in
fachpublikationen werfen ich habe hier
eine mitgebracht military technology 121
das sehen sie ein kampf fahrzeug das für
erben warfare entsprechend ausgestattet
ist und dass hier sehr wohl auch für
panzer einsatzmöglichkeiten im urbanen
gefecht das ja derzeit ein schwergewicht
darstellt gesehen werden
es wird hier etwa vom zusatzausstattung
geredet wie ein dilemma das sind also
technische vorrichtungen die explosionen
von straßenbomben unterdrücken leser
warnung teleskopmasten zur beobachtung
der häuserzeilen reaktiv panzerung bis
hin zu räumschild das heißt die
weiterentwicklung dieser fahrzeuge
neue rollen und neu einsatzzwecke ebenso
wird dem schutz gegenüber neue
technologien wie etwa den drohnen hier
eine entsprechende aufmerksamkeit zu
widmen sein
wesentlich ist aus meiner sicht dass
auch im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
trotz aller technologie schübe räume und
objekte nur durch truppen entsprechend
genommen und gehalten werden können und
daran wird auch die entwicklung
autonomer technologien zunächst nichts
ändern wenn wir nun den blick auf das
österreichische bundesheer richten so
sind diese gepanzerten kräfte in der
vierten panzergrenadierbrigade
zusammengefasst die sozusagen
dehnfähigkeit kern dieser robusten
kräfte für das österreichische
bundesheer darstellen und wie ich
anfangs ausgeführt habe natürlich im
hinblick auf die größenordnung nur noch
eine minimale vorsorge repräsentieren
insbesondere auch deshalb weil seit der
einführung dieser beiden haupt systeme
ende der 90er jahre kaum investitionen
erfolgten
dennoch darf ich hier einflechten dass
das kaderpersonal dieser verbände sind
drei bataillone in wall street und
großen mittel großartige leistungen
erbracht haben und zwar auch
international es gibt ein amerikanisches
programm das nennt sich rang european
und hat die stärkung europäische armeen
zum ziel und im rahmen dieser strand
european tank challenge hat etwa ein
österreichischer panzer zug ausfällt
2017 den ersten platz errungen in diesem
wettkampf und 2018 immerhin den dritten
platz
warum können diese leistungen erbracht
werden weil das kaderpersonal die
soldatinnen und soldaten mit sehr viel
eigeninitiative an der technischen
einsatzbereitschaft ihrer ansicht
veralteten geräte arbeiten die frau
bundesminister hat mich nun beauftragt
den sachstand zu erheben und die
modernisierung dieser truppe
unverzüglich einzuleiten
zielsetzung ist die erhaltung der
fähigkeiten und lebensdauer verlängerung
der haupt systeme leopard und uran bis
gleichzeitig soll eine hohe
wertschöpfung in österreich erzielt
werden
das wird bei milan mit general dynamics
sehr naheliegend sein aber auch bei
leopard wo die haupt provider in
deutschland beheimatet sind wird es eine
beteiligung österreichischer firmen beim
notwendigen sanierungsmaßnahmen geben
beziehungsweise wird eine solche
anzustreben seien
dieses vorhaben befindet sich durchaus
auch im konsens des regierungsprogrammes
wo ja die stärkung der privaten als eine
zielsetzung ausgewiesen ist
diese maßnahmen werden den dringend
gebotenen fähigkeit erhalt gewährleisten
und auch die grundlage für erforderliche
weiterentwicklung an bilden diese
sanierung kann naturgemäß meine damen
und herren nur schrittweise erfolgen und
sie erfordert natürlich auch
budgetmittel wie auch bei anderen
waffengattungen kann der
investitionsstau nicht kurzfristig
abgebaut werden wesentlich ist aber dass
zeitnah erste maßnahmen eingeleitet
werden und die engagierten soldatinnen
und soldaten der panzer und fahrzeuge
notiert truppe wissen dass sie wichtige
aufgabenträger im bundesheer sind und
bleiben
herzlichen dank
der bundesminister der gerade sehr
geehrte damen und herren ich darf in den
nächsten minuten ein bisschen weiterhin
die details eindringen dessen was das
bundesheer sich vorgenommen hat und was
aufgrund der nun verfügbaren finde einen
finanziellen mittel auch machbar
erscheint wie vom herrn general bereits
angesprochen ist es allerdings ein
schrittweises vorgehen und die wärme
darauf konzentrieren was für 2020
gemacht haben bzw
worauf wir vor allem 20 21 unsere
schwergewicht erleben etwa funde aus der
folie bieten wir haben das so aufgebaut
dass wir auf der nächsten folie dann
sehen es ganz wesentlich und ersten
punkt nach vorangestellt die
verbesserung der ausrüstung unserer
soldaten
wir müssen unsere soldaten immerhin
55.000 präsenz und miliz auf einen
entsprechenden technologischen standard
bringen und auch entsprechend ausbilden
können und symbolhaft habe ich in der
mitte hier das neue sturmgewehr 77 das
einem update unterzogen wird
aufgezeichnet rechts daneben zu sehen
der soldat wie wir uns in zukunft
vorstellen der soll in der nacht kämpfen
und sehen können dazu braucht ein
entsprechendes funkgerät dazu braucht
der nachtsicht mittel und ein
ordentliches sturmgewehr
wir müssen aber auch entsprechend
ausbilden und ausbildung ist nicht mehr
das was ich vielleicht noch in einer
grundausbildung erlebt habe wir haben
heute moderne technologie simulation
gibt uns ganz ganz viele möglichkeiten
und das ist etwas wo wir im bundesheer
wirklich stolz darauf sein auf das was
wir schon haben aber hier bleiben wir
entsprechend auch am stand der dinge und
ich habe auch ein symbolbild mitgebracht
zum beispiel von einem modernen
schießkino wo man seine
grundfertigkeiten auch ohne einsatz von
durchaus teurer munition einmal erlernen
kann und dann draußen wirklich wirkt auf
der nächsten folie ein in den
vergangenen jahren sehr prominentes
thema die mobilität dass der drucker des
bundesheeres und natürlich ist heute
links rechts oben
links und links um dargestellt der
mannschaftstransportwagen panzerband uhr
eines unserer kernstücke für das
österreichische bundesheer die
geschützte mobilität unserer infanterie
und sonstiger truppen die wir ins
gefecht bringen müssen im inland oder
auch im ausland dass sie geschützt von a
nach b transportiert werden können ist
heute eine selbstverständlichkeit die
zeiten wo man auf lkws ins gefecht fahrt
müssen
alsbald wenn man einmal vorsichtig der
vergangenheit angehören und erste
wichtige schritte könnten hier gesetzt
werden unternehmen dargestellt der regel
uns der ist ja allgemein bekannter
großer schritt für die gebirgstruppe ist
ein geschütztes fahrzeug mal tirol fähig
schwimmt und dann auch entsprechend
waffen zur zum einsatz bringen
aber ich habe auch mitgebracht wie
beiden dinge in der mitte und links und
rechts links unten
die man vielleicht oft nicht so
betrachtet lkws funktionsfahrzeuge sie
erinnern sich an der diskussion um die
ablöse buch geben
auch hier sind wir jetzt auf dem weg
diese fahrzeuge zu ersetzen und wieder
her generalstabschef vorher bereits
ausgeführt hat die verbesserung kampf
wird erhalt der mechanisierten truppe
hier dargestellt durch den
schützenpanzer ulan ist uns ein
wesentliches anliegen weil ihm die
panzergrenadiere der wesentliche
rückhalt der landstreitkräfte sind auf
der nächsten folie dafür kurz darstellen
abc abwehr und sanität auch so etwas was
man vielleicht nicht immer mitbekommt
dass das sanitätsdienst im bundes jahr
ganz wesentliche rolle spielt die
versorgung unserer soldaten seien sie
verletzt oder verwundet ist ganz einfach
eine selbstverständlichkeit für
streitkräfte und dass wir hier ein
modernes transportfahrzeug das geschützt
verwunderte oder verletzte wieder von
einem aus als ort verbringen können ist
er ganz großer wichtiger schritt nach
vorne
das gesamte bundesheer wird in den
nächsten jahren mit 60.000
schutzmasken ausgestattet zeitgemäß war
irgendwann mal wird der beste gummi
porös ist das höchste zeit die
entsprechend auszutauschen und auch
symbolhaft für andere anschaffungen
haben wir entsprechend investiert in
tanklöschfahrzeuge verschiedenste die
pioniere stehen mit ihrer
katastrophenhilfe fähigkeit aber auch
mit ihrer fähigkeit im einsatz
verschiedenste aufgaben wahrzunehmen ob
das minen räumen oder camps errichten
ist immer wieder im mittelpunkt und hier
haben wir schon einige dinge vor wir
haben die boote links unten dargestellt
in einer generalsanierung des erhält im
österreichischen bundesheer die
fähigkeit zum beispiel auf der donau
oder auf anderen großen gewässern fairen
betreiben zu können
das braucht man sowohl militärisch war
nicht immer sichergestellt dass eine
brücke auch nutzbar ist wenn man sie
gerade nutzen möchte aber natürlich auch
in einem katastropheneinsatz bei dem
berge fahrzeugen ganz modernes team das
wir hier in der zusammenarbeit mit einem
deutschen konzern erworben haben das
bringt der druck befahren eine fähigkeit
ihre schweren fahrzeuge zu bergen oder
zu schleppen und mit dem kran können
entsprechende schwere geräte auch
gehandelt werden und wir machen einen
schritt mit symbolfoto hier dargestellt
nachdem es noch keine typen entscheidung
gibt auch hier in gepanzerte systeme zu
investieren der pionierpanzer ist
wirklich in die jahre gekommen ich bin
1988 eingerückt und das hat es damals
auch schon gegeben also das ist schon
eine zeit lang im bestand des
bundesheeres sie können sich vorstellen
dass hier motor hydraulik über die jahre
entsprechend nicht mehr so state of the
art sein wie man sich das vorstellt und
hier werden wir beginnen im nächsten
jahr die beschaffung einzuleiten
ganz ein wesentlicher bereich bringe
dann auf der nächsten folie selber und
ekd das zukunftsfeld für alle
streitkräfte
leider sind halt andere dinge nicht
weggegangen die anderen bedrohungen gibt
es weiterhin
sie sind nur durch das
elektromagnetische spektrum und durch
den ganzen bereich der informations und
kommunikationstechnologie erweitert
worden und das ist für streitkräfte eine
große herausforderung einerseits hier
immer state of the art zu bleiben
zu wissen was die gegner potenziell
können weil wir sehen das natürlich
moderne informations- und
kommunikationstechnologie auch weit
verbreitet in händen ist wo wir uns
eigentlich wünschen dass sie das nicht
hätten und somit auch unsere soldaten
sich darauf vorbereiten müssen
drohnen und thronen abwehr ist hier ein
ganz ein großes thema armenien
aserbaidschan der konflikt hat gezeigt
wohin es in weiterer folge gehen wird
selber die fans aufbau von kapazitäten
vor allem einmal um zeitgemäß und das
ist ein wettlauf mit der zeit zeitgemäß
die fähigkeiten so zu erhalten dass wir
unsere eigenen netze uns unsere eigene
einsatzführung sicherstellen können
heute ist jedes funkgerät im
wesentlichen ein kleiner computer und
jederzeit angreifbar wir investieren
aber auch in andere dinge wie ihnen
grundsätzlich neues system für die
kommunikation im gesamten bundesheer und
zum abschluss noch ein paar worte zur
luft zu den hubschraubern und zu den
trainern drohnen ein großes thema hier
werden wir entsprechend investieren wir
stehen mit dem trecker denn wir haben
bereits mit einem fuß in der neuen zeit
werden aber hier auch noch weitere
schritte für drohnen im niedrigen
bereich setzen und natürlich werden wir
raten wir dringend auf den neuen
hubschrauber und adrett abzulösen die
arbeit 169 und auch die black hawks
staffel wird einerseits um drei
luftfahrzeugen erweitert und
andererseits werden die neuen die wir
schon haben eine modifikation und clan
verteidigungsprogramm unterzogen
das bringt dann schon einen großen
schritt auch dorthin weiter dass wir die
anforderungen die wir haben eine
kompanie des bundesheeres in einem lift
zu transportieren auch wirklich
sicherstellen zu können
herr bundesminister ja genial
die damen und herren der iss beendet
meine kurze bürgern über das was wir uns
vorgenommen haben
danke schön viel eigentlich bitten um
ihre fragen das muss zu warten bis das
mikrofon bei dennis bitte danke schön
frau ministerin jetzt haben wir gehört
in einigen bereichen wird viel mehr geld
in die hand genommen vielleicht können
sie nur noch einmal zusammenfassen wie
viel denn insgesamt und sind das
zusätzliche mittel oder ist das im
rahmen der der bereits ausverhandelten
budgets und zweite frage noch es gibt
jetzt nach diesem vorfall mit dieser
party in einer kaserne wo sie dann eben
ein video gegeben hat mit sexuellen
handlungen und den selbstmord eines der
beteiligten soldaten gibt es jetzt auch
kritik am umgang des bundesheers damit
auch homophobe äußerungen sagen
homosexuellenverbände hat es da gegeben
kritisiert wird vor allem auch eine
aussage dass homosexuelle dazu haben
andere zu handlungen gezwungen hätten
da wollte ich fragen wie sie das als
ministerin sehen was sie dazu sagen
ich beginne mit dem ersten teil der
frage das sind zusätzlich zum zweimal
erhöhten rege budget sondern invest
pakete gesamt über 600 millionen euro in
den genannten bereichen teilweise 25
millionen euro für das erste jahr noch
einmal 25 für das zweite aber zusätzlich
eben zum zum regel budget ich würde
ihnen gerne die genaue auflistung für
die einzelnen bereiche dann noch
mitgeben zu ihrer zweiten frage lassen
sie mich an dieser stelle meine
betroffenheit ausdrücken über
den selbstmord eines der von ihnen
angesprochenen soldaten furchtbar für
die familie und ja auch mein
aufrichtiges beileid an erster stelle
ist es mir wichtig festzuhalten dass
homophobie im österreichischen
bundesheer nichts verloren hat
an zweiter stelle ist mir eines wichtig
die einzelfälle die bekannt geworden
sind in den vergangenen wochen dürfen
uns den blick auf eines nicht verstellen
da ist es mir wichtig dass ich mich
schützend vor die soldatinnen und
soldaten und auch für die vor zivilen
bediensteten meines ressorts stelle die
in masse großartige arbeit leisten und
die jetzt darunter leiden müssen dass
der so mühsam erkämpfte ansehen dass das
bundesheer nicht zuletzt aufgrund der
zahlreichen einsätze in zusammenhang mit
der pandemie gewonnen hat die jetzt
darunter leiden
diese dinge muss man unterscheiden jeden
einzelnen fall nachverfolgen und dann
sofort die konsequenz nach ziehen
das heißt display rechtlich und
strafrechtlich und das ist in jedem
einzelnen dieser fälle passiert ich
hoffe ich habe ihre frage damit
ausreichend beantwortet
der fall ist aus ihrer sicht
abgeschlossen es gibt keine weiteren
konsequenzen sprechen sie von den fällen
in güssing oder sprechen sie von dem
einen falles eines unteroffiziers weil
in diesem wird eben noch ermittelt daher
müsste man genau die einzelnen vorkommen
ist unterscheiden in all diesen fällen
sind die zuständige disziplinarbehörde
neben befassung treffen dann auch die
entscheidung ob eben die strafbehörden
auch mit einbezogen werden
nächste frage bitte von der frau
ministerin kristina luftraumüberwachung
war das dem ganzen ein wenig
ausgeklammert gibt es da neue aspekte
oder neue dreh ist wie geht es jetzt
weiter nach beschaffung des ups oder
nicht immer diese entschieden aber haben
sie doch längerfristig weitere vorhaben
wie schaut es mit der perspektive für
die eurofighter aus wie schaut es mit
ihrem vorhaben aus die
parlamentsparteien da entwickelt zum
einen das ausscheiden der saab 105 ist
einfach dem ende der technischen
funktionsfähigkeit geschuldet und in
verantwortung nicht zuletzt auch für die
pilotinnen und piloten mussten wir diese
entscheidung treffen
die luftraumüberwachung die aktive
luftraumüberwachung ist gesichert sie
wissen das wird durch die eurofighter
durchgeführt davon zu unterscheiden sind
noch anhängige gerichtsverfahren gegen
das unternehmen airbus die durch den
anwalt der republik
die finanzprokuratur auch weiter
betrieben werden an dieser stelle es mir
auch wichtig festzuhalten dass es für
mich nach wie vor nicht nachvollziehbar
ist wenn ein konzernen unternehmen
malversationen zugibt
der staaten schadenersatz erhalten haben
dass wir österreich nicht gilt
aber sie wissen auch wir leben in einem
rechtsstaat und diese verfahren gegen
jetzt eben in den händen der justiz das
weitere ist dass wir sie wissen ja in
ein angebot bekommen haben
beziehungsweise interesse bekundet wurde
an unseren eurofighter nicht nur
interesse bekundet sondern der
indonesische verteidigungsminister war
er auch hier bei uns weil diese eben
abfangjäger benötigen als
überbrückungslösung bis sie neue
angeschafft haben
da ist der stand jetzt so dass alsbald
xd vieles verzögert sich nicht zuletzt
auch durch die beschränkten
reisemöglichkeiten in zusammenhang mit
der coop 19
dass ein termin stattfinden soll der
insbesondere mit unseren experten
stattfinden soll und ermöglichen soll
dass auch die die eurofighter technisch
begutachtet werden das heißt es ist im
laufe der nächste schritt ist dass das
ihr 1 1 vor ort besuch auch stattfindet
und dann wird man sehen ob eine
möglichkeit besteht hier zu einem
abschluss zu kommen was hat sich in dem
bereich der luftraumüberwachung noch
getan
es gibt ja nicht nur die aktive
luftraumüberwachung sondern auch die
passive luftraumüberwachung und auch das
wurde hier nicht erwähnt weil wie gesagt
wir so vieles zu tun haben dass das mit
sicherheit nicht eine abschließende
aufzählung der investitionen ist in
unser gold haben systeme im bereich der
passiven luftraumüberwachung ist ja
bereits investiert worden das jedoch
zukünftiger notwendig seien
wir haben auch eine in diesem
ministerrat die woche in zusammenhang
mit der luftraumüberwachung ein abkommen
mit deutschland unterzeichnet sie wissen
es gibt der eines bereits mit der
schweiz
den fragen der nach halle und das ist
auch diese woche passiert grundsätzlich
beschäftigt sich nicht nur österreich
und nicht nur das österreichische
bundesheer mit der machbarkeit der
finanzierung der frage der aktiven
luftraumüberwachung das machen sehr
viele andere staaten auch und so
beschäftigen uns auch wir mit der frage
inwiefern eine intensivere auch
grenzüberschreitende zusammenarbeit in
diesen bereichen möglich ist abgehandelt
wie gesagt im bereich der nachteile
derzeit in einem abkommen mit der
schweiz und mit deutschland zu sehen
dazu noch war das
wenn sie mich fragen ja natürlich habe
ich eine frau wie geht es dann weiter in
ein werden wir werden sie tatsächlich
die europäer loswerden dass er
offensichtlich die gewünschte
perspektive ist was war was ist dann
schauen sie wenn es für den steuerzahler
die richtige entscheidung ist und wir
dadurch geld erlösen können dann wird
uns das wohl recht sein sie haben ja
genau gesehen wie viele
investitionsbedarf wir haben dennoch
haben wir dann die verpflichtung zu
einem vollkommen recht auch weiterhin
die aktive luftraum überwachung
sicherzustellen
aber es wäre ja nicht das erste mal dass
man hier sozusagen eine übergangslösung
findet das hat sie aufgegeben
in der vergangenheit sie wissen dass
beim übergang von den tragen auf die
eurofighter
das ist in all diesen
beschaffungsvorgängen ja nicht nur in
der luft sondern auch zu land und im
wasser notwendig weil diese eben immer
auch eine geraume zeit in anspruch
nehmen aber es braucht niemand die sorge
haben dass der luftraum nicht gesichert
ist denn unsere eurofighter sind nicht
zuletzt und da darf ich vielleicht das
was der generalstabschef für unsere
panzerbrigade festgehalten hat auch da
festhalten auch unsere techniker in
technik und piloten im bereich des
eurofighter systems sind sind wirklich
großartig keiten dieses system zumindest
so wie auch in anderen staaten aufrecht
dass er keine sorge haben muss
aber wie ist die perspektive die sie
tatsächlich können sie jetzt fix zu
sagen dass es auch weiter eine aktive
österreichische luftraum überwachung mit
österreichischen gerät geben wird wenn
einmal die eurofighter zeit vorbei ist
oder ist es für sie tatsächlich eine
perspektive das komplett in kooperation
mit zu kaufen mit irgendeiner form der
nachbarstaaten österreichs luftraum auch
überwacht ist das für sie auch die ich
weiß nicht was sie mit österreichischen
gerät meinen aber natürlich muss
wirklich sagen
fakt ist fakt ist dass wir vom und das
war gemeinde mit dem beschäftigen sowie
dass er andere staaten auch tun
fakt ist dass wir nicht zuletzt auch
verfassungsrechtlich dazu verpflichtet
sind unseren luftraum zu schützen
das meint man landläufig geben mit
aktiver luftraumüberwachung und dieses
tun wir mit der zeit eben mit den
eurofightern ich persönlich bin aber der
meinung dass wir uns wehren ab und das
war ja wenn wir in die vergangenheit
blicken immer wieder herausfordernd
fernab vom parteipolitischen
einzelinteressen uns damit beschäftigen
müssen wie wir mittel- und langfristig
unsere lufträume sichern das betrifft ja
nicht nur österreich sondern sie wissen
ja auch dass in der schweizer ist vor
geraumer zeit eine volksbefragung zu
diesem thema auch stattgefunden
stattgefunden hat alle staaten sind
damit konfrontiert dass sie unter dem
budget zwängen
dennoch die notwendigkeit haben ihren
luftraum zu schützen und wenn sie auch
vom verfassungsrechtlichen möglichkeiten
gibt dass sie in einer engeren
abstimmung zu tun dann werden wir uns
damit natürlich auch vom rechtlichen
aspekten beschäftigen kollegen
und ministerin südtirol schon
angesprochen wenn sie da einmal noch
erläutern könnten wie sehen da genau die
aufgaben aus die das aus die das
bundesheer übernehmen wäre das irgendwie
fernblieb das bundesheer hier
unterstützen und es gibt schwere
vorwürfe gegen finanzminister blümel
die opposition fordert jetzt geschlossen
seinen rücktritt wie sehen sie als
mittäter bundesregierung dieser
rücktrittsforderungen
ich beginne mit tirol ich glaube die
zeit brauche ich vielleicht nicht nicht
noch einmal nicht noch einmal
wiederholen wie sie aktive neben heute
mit der notwendigkeit aufgestockt worden
worden sind die aufgaben sind immer
diejenigen die uns im gesundheits
behördliche assistenz sozusagen auch
aufgetragen werden das heißt sowohl an
den grenzen neben den aufgaben die wir
ein zusammenhang mit dem grenzschutz und
mit migration zu erfüllen haben die
gesundheitsbehörde kontrolle ebendort es
nach den vorgaben des
gesundheitsministeriums beziehungsweise
der zuständigen gesundheitsbehörden des
landes tirol vereinfacht gesagt alle
kontrollen die notwendig sind gemeinsam
erfüllt zu werden
mit den kräften eben auch der polizei
insbesondere an den grenzen nicht nur an
den außengrenzen sondern auch in
österreich und in enger absprache auch
mit der polizei
der zweiter der zweite punkt ich habe
diese woche schon eines gesagt für mich
etwas verwunderlich dass das die
verständigung nicht sofort erfolgt
erfolgt erfolgt ist
für mich persönlich ist eines ganz klar
dass kein cent geflossen ist in der
fraglichen zeit wieder an die bundes
partei noch an die landespartei weil
immer schon klar gestellt worden ist das
spenden von glücksspielunternehmen
waffenproduzenten oder der ba konzernen
auch nicht angenommen werden das hat der
minister gernot blume gestern auch sehr
klar gemacht es gibt ja auch klare
beweise dazu die spendenliste der partei
ist ja auch öffentlich einsehbar und ist
auch geprüft worden
vom rechnungshof und ohr ich persönlich
halte das für übereilte und reflexartige
vorverurteilungen gut gibt's weitere
fragen wenn das nicht der fall ist und
sage ich herzlichen dank für kommen und
beendete pressekonferenz
dankeschön